Creating a user interface for your machine
learning model can make it easier to adjust
the model and visualize the results. Great yo
is a Python library that makes it super easy
for machine learning engineers to create intuitive
user interfaces. In this course, Abdul will teach
you all aspects of radio, including deployment.
Dear fellow coders, welcome to one little coder,
radio machine learning AP course 2021. I
welcome you to this course. And in this course,
you will learn the fastest way to demonstrate your
machine learning model using gradient gradients,
a Python library, and we are going to learn more
about gradients in this course. Follow us on
YouTube to learn more about machine learning data
science and analytics. This course contains nine
sections, and this course runs about one hour 15
minutes. Let's get started understanding what is
this course content. The first thing is you will
learn what is the current problem that we have
in the ML prototyping space. And then you will
learn about advantages of radio and what is radio.
Next, you will learn how to get started with
radio with a very simple example to create your
first radio web application. And next, there are a
lot of different components of radio. So you have
component for image of component for text, you
have different components, and in this section,
you will learn the different components of
radio. And in the next section, you will
learn how to handle multiple inputs and multiple
outputs in a typical radio application. And next,
you will learn about debugging your radio
application, and also using a very special
feature that radio has got called flagging.
And next, you will learn how to improve your
radio applications user interface and user
experience. This section will also help you
understand how can you change the theme and also
have your own style in your video application.
And next, you will learn how to share the
video application with everybody in the world,
and also how to add security which means add an
authentication layer at the top so that way only
people whom you want to take the video application
to can check. And finally we are going to finish
this course with a capstone project where we
are going to build a Gradle application that is
powered by deep learning and that deep learning
powered radio application, we will learn how to
deploy it on hugging face spaces. So starting from
understanding the space to completely deploy this
application on a permanent hosting, you will
learn everything from scratch to end to end
in this one hour 15 minutes course, which is
about nine sections. If you do not have time for
all the nine sections of the scores. What I've
done here is at this this particular page, you
can actually see that there are certain things,
those have been highlighted. And those highlighted
things are the most important thing. If you only
cover these important things, you will be able to
build a decent radio application. So if you do
not have time for everything else, you can at
least go fast track with these highlighted items.
And that will give you the necessary knowledge
to build a great new application, which you can
use to demonstrate your machine learning model.
Let's get started with the course. And I
hope you will find this course valuable.
In this section, we'll learn a little bit
about the challenges that we have in building
a machine learning web application, especially for
prototyping. So if you go to Google, and then say
machine learning web app, using then you will
certainly see a lot of suggestions like flask
is the Code Stream latest area code Jango, Sasha
got all these suggestions. So the first problem
that you usually face when you want to build a
machine learning web application for prototyping,
let's say or even I can say that machine
learning, machine learning web app, proto type
web app using Yep. So if you see this thing, now
you'll you'll see a lot of a lot of suggestions.
flask is there. Again, the extremely it is there,
you will see Django somewhere. So the first
problem that you have is, what is the solution
that I should pick for my current need. And it
could be anything, right? So you have solutions
varying from flask to Django, to streamlet.
And a lot of other solutions exist in this space,
especially in recent times, if you see a lot of
new applications or libraries that helped that
that is there to create web application around
your machine learning a data science model. So
for example, solutions, like for example, if I go
online and then look for streamlet versus flask,
versus then you see Django dash then vs. Then
you see grid view. So basically, if you see the
current space, you have all these different Python
libraries that is there to create that is there
to help you create a web application and on your
machine learning solution. So it is very important
for you to understand what is the problem that
we have in the current space The problem that
we have in the current space is that you have
either applications like flask, which is usually
used for a full stack web application using Python
ecosystem flask or Django for that matter. Or you
have something like streamlet, which is, which is,
again, a very good application library for you
to create ml web application, or even any web
application of that sort. You can even build
a streamlined dashboard analytical dashboard.
And you can, you can do everything with streamlet.
But you don't need the level of knowledge of flask
or Django, because streamlet helps you wrap around
all important components in the form of stimulate
and you have got stimulated, but components.
So now when you see a world video chord,
stream rate and video, I've got flask and Django.
Now you would start wondering, what is the one
that I need to pick. And because this course
is about grade, you, I would like to highlight
that as grade you fit in this stack. So if you've
see, like, let's go to the examples available on
hugging face spaces. So this is hugging face
spaces where we have got a bunch of applications
available. Okay. So now when you go to spaces, and
then look for one of the most popular spaces like
these are the spaces of the week. So if I look at
one of the most popular spaces, when I click it,
it's running. And you can you can actually see
a great view application popping up. So this is
this is built with grid view. So you have an
input text, and then you need you can you can
do anything like multilingual summarization model,
and then you have the ability to select languages.
And then you have an output design. So this
is the typical use case where you want to
use radio or any other solution. So my pitch
here is, let's say you want to build a startup.
And that startup should have like high
scalability and then you want like a
production grade application, not now. Now
this is the time probably you would start using
flask or Django because that's what people do. So
you have a flask developer or a Django developer,
and then you put together a full stack
development team. And then you can start
production using your application, will it let's
say, like you're building the next Facebook,
next Google or whatever the next is, right? If you
are in that condition, if you are in that state,
then you know, for the web application that we are
talking about, for the machine learning powered
web application that we are talking about,
you need a solution that is quite scalable,
that can handle a lot of different
things, not just only machine learning,
but you know a lot of different things. So you
would probably go with Flask, or Django. And
let's say like you are in a space where your
solution is very confined to machine learning,
especially data science machine learning,
you want to build a dashboard, you want a
tableau alternative. You want easy wrappers
around machine learning, you want like simple
third party components, I would probably
prefer to go with streaming it there.
Streaming, it is highly flexible, I love streaming
it. And streaming, it also makes it easier for you
to deploy. Okay, so this is where streaming.
Now in this process in this entire process,
let's say you want to build an MVP, what is
an MVP? MVP stands for minimum viable product.
This is a product that you would build
to gain your customer confidence to find
out product market fit. To find out whether
this is a product that people want to use.
That is an MVP. The second thing is while
your machine learning team is creating models,
you want to make sure that you have the best
model in place, you have the best in class
state of the art model that is available for
your customer. And so you which means you're
going to build a lot of models, like you're going
to do an experiment probably weights and biases,
karma and Neptune whatever solution that you use
for experiment, but at the same time, you also
want somebody to actually play with the model that
you have built. So now we are talking about two
cases. One, you want to build an MVP minimum
viable product for your startup. Or second,
you want to build a web application that is used
for iterating your machine learning solution.
Now, if you are in this situation, either of
these situation, I would strongly recommend
using radio because radio is specially built for
this purpose, or at least in my opinion, like you
could talk Gradius founder, and then probably that
person might have a different opinion. But if you
asked me, if you look at Radio, if you are in a
corporate setup, or if you're a hobby hobbyist,
Mission hobbyist, or if you are somebody
who's trying to build web application,
or like machine learning startup, like you could
be an entrepreneur, you could be in academia,
you could be a normal data scientists like to
build data scientists like me, or you could
be a hardcore machine learning engineer who's
working for Facebook, artificial intelligence
research, or Google Brain or some kind of
organization, you could be any of these things.
Now, one of the things that you would do across
all these different verticals is that you need to
iterate on your machine learning application. You
need to build an MVP before your startup looks,
you know, like go speak. So in that case, I would
strongly prefer radio because gradient gives that
flexibility to build something like very fast very
soon without having to be worried about you know,
scalability without having to be worried about
deployment without having to be worried about
what is the CSS style looks like? What
is the style? How do I have to change my,
you know, style, like what, how does the head
headline or text should look like, I don't have
to be worried about any of these things. Because
this is a phase, where I'm going to, if I'm,
if I'm an entrepreneur, I'm going to probably
focus on you know, finding the product market fit,
making more people use my product and finding how
they feel about it, like how they feel about the
solution. Or if I'm in academia, or if I'm
in like building machine learning solution,
I will be probably more interested in finding the
best model that I can serve my customers with.
So if you are caught in this situation,
so you're not building the next Facebook,
you're not building the next Twitter, you are not
even you know, building an analytics dashboard,
if you are in this situation, but still you want
to have application that is to be created fast,
that is to be created and shared with everybody.
And that also has, you know, some flexibility to
deploy permanently, then I would like completely
support picking a gradient for this purpose,
because I strongly feel gradient is used for this
purpose. So if you come across a question like
radio versus stream lit versus flask versus Django
anywhere on the internet, then probably my take
on that is you have to use different products,
different libraries, for different stages of your
product lifecycle, if you're an entrepreneur. So
if you are in an MVP phase, I would close my eyes
and then pick radio. If you are in a phase where
I'm going to deploy my production grade machine
learning solution, I would probably go with,
like, if it is only a machine learning solution,
but it's only a machine learning solution,
probably I would go with streamlet, again, like
slightly an enhanced version of me MVP. But if you
want like a production grade solution, like let's
say I'm building the next Facebook or Twitter or
something, then I would probably go with Django,
something that has people, something that people
usually use for production grade web application,
something that can compete with the JavaScript
ecosystem. So this is how I usually see this
problem. But you can see the natural problem that
we have here, the problem that we have here is
not about which solution to pick. But generally,
if you want to build a web application,
you don't want like, you don't want a public
building a web application to be an overhead
for your current problem. So your current problem
is solving a machine learning problem. And you
have to just solve that you cannot sit and spend
your time on learning how to you know, connect
your API is within Java, like a flask, you cannot,
you cannot think about how to you know, get your
app routed to a particular link, you cannot do all
those things. These are like roadblocks. These can
inhibit your progress in your machine learning,
research or application or whatever you do,
right? Whether it is machine learning research
or applied machine learning, you don't want a
solution that can stay in your way prohibiting
inhibiting your progress in doing something
greater than just building an application, you
want a solution that should make it much, much
easier, just like icing on the cake. To enable you
build a web application that can help you serve
your web application. So that can help you serve
your machine learning solution as an application
that the entire world can use, I would strongly
pick radio. So if you are wondering why radio,
then you do have the answer in this video, which
is to say that I would pick radio whenever I want
to show machine learning demo whenever I want
people to use my models. And I want to build
an MVP. And whenever I want people to actually
you know, play with a model and iterate on it
and then find the best solution. So internal or
external, customer facing or internal, you know,
like machine learning engineers, iterating,
whatever this is, this is a place where I
would probably pick Grady over any other existing
solution because every solution has its own place
in the machine learning lifecycle or product
development lifecycle. So for this particular
phase, I would pre grade you and then we will
learn more about grade you as well in this course.
A quick introduction to grade you. What is
gradient gradient is the fastest way to demo
your machine learning model with a friendly
web interface, so that anybody can use it
anywhere in the world. So gradient has this pitch
that says, Build unshared, delightful machine
learning applications with anybody in the world.
And what does it mean? It means if you have to
demo demonstrate your machine learning model, you
don't have to create a full stack web application.
Rather, what you can do is you can wrap your
function with gray do and then gradient would
be able to create a web interface for you. As you
can see on the screen, it says, with five lines of
pure Python code, you should be able to create
a UI around your machine learning application.
Let's look at the example here. So let's look at
this sketch recognition. So you've got handwriting
recognition, machine learning model or sketch
recognizing machine learning model. And then you
want to create a web application around it for
people to use it. For people to experience how
good your machine learning model is, it could be
a that you are creating a demo for somebody else.
Or it could be that you want to yourself, check
the validity of your machine learning model,
the efficiency of your machine learning model.
So for you to do all these things, if you have
a web application that you can play around with,
that is a great, great way for you to learn how
your model is performing. And usually, typically,
it's not an easy task for you to do. And gradient
makes it really, really easy. If you see this
code here for sketch recognition, the first step
is import the library, then wrap your sketch
recognition model everything within a function
and use that function as a radio interface. And
the input in your image, you can see that the
input image, which is the input for the function
has been given as an input image here, and then
output you're going to label the output like the
display the output. So let's go ahead and then try
to use this application and then see how it works.
So you have got a canvas here. And this canvas has
an attachment output. So you have an input, and
you have an output. So let me clear this. And then
you can see there is like there is nothing here,
right? So I'm going to clear this and then say,
three, okay, this looks like three, yeah, you
can see that it has gone to the machine learning
model, and the machine learning more or less,
try to figure out what is this, and then it has
given you the output score. So this is the easiest
way, let me let me write something very ambiguous.
Okay, so I'm going to write like this. Okay,
for not very ambiguous. So if I do like this,
yeah, so now, you know, it doesn't know whether
I'm trying to write nine or six or for whatever
it is, right? So this is how you can actually
see, okay, where are the places your machine
learning model is not doing good. And then you can
probably fix that. And that is, that is one of the
advantages of using radio, because radio lets
you do that with a very, very simple interface,
all you have to do is wrap around your machine
learning functions, whatever you're doing within
within our like main function, here speech
recognition, and use that function as an input
to the radio interface. So that is your input. And
all you have to do is import the radio library and
like that, you can see couple of other examples
that is there on the website, question and answer
you. So you have got a question. So the idea here
is that you can use it for computer vision tasks,
just like this. You can use it for NLP
tasks, like a question and answer generation,
you can use it for speech recognition, like
you can speech detection and translation,
text to speech, speech to text. And also if
you want to, you know, Mark some mark some like
segmentation within your image, you can still do
that. So these are like all the examples. And the
one thing that common you would see across all
these examples is that you import the library,
you wrap it around the function, and then you have
the grade your interface, skates, recognition,
question and answer and everything you would
see the same thing. It might be that you know,
the number of inputs differ, like, for example, in
this case, you have got two inputs, right? But but
the fundamentals are same, you do the same thing,
and then it just helps you create that interface.
Okay, so now we know that radio is an application
or like a Python library that can help you create
easy web interfaces for your machine learning
model that could be shared with anybody. Let's
look at some of the companies that are using
radio. So if you see the logos that are available
here, you can actually see that almost all reputed
companies that use machine learning model you can
see like Google is their Amazon is their Facebook
is that you can call it meta, whatever you want.
Cisco is they're hugging faces. They're
VMware Siemens, like all these companies,
and also educational institutes like MIT and
Stanford, all of them are using radio. So this is,
again for you to gain a confidence that this
solution is there to exist. It's not a solution,
you know, that's bi, that is just used by a bunch
of hobbyists, gray area is a solution that is
being used at corporate level and academic level.
And it is a way forward for you to demonstrate
your machine learning model, if you are not using
radio. So what are the advantages of using radio.
So first of all, Gradius quite easy and fast
to setup. All you have to do is install radio.
And you all know like, if you're in the Python
ecosystem, you know that all you have to do is
pip install radio. And creating a great audio
interface requires one only a couple of lines
of Python code to your existing project, which
means you don't have to change a lot of things
in your code existing code because that shouldn't
the objective of creating a user interface for
your machine learning model shouldn't be shouldn't
be a roadblock in your machine learning itself. So
that's the whole point of Grady, right. So
it's that you just have a machine learning
model and all you wanted to do is create a
UI now You don't have to deal with you know,
a lot of API's, you don't have to deal with a lot
of new classes, a lot of new libraries, the whole
advantage. And the point objective of gradient
is that you keep your machine learning code as
it is. And all you have to do is add a couple
of lines of Python code like pure Python code.
And then that entire script is now turned into
a UI user interface that anybody can play with.
So So that's, that's the greatest thing.
So fast and easy setup, that's a very good
advantage that you have got the first.
The next thing is, you can present this
as part of a lot of things. For example, you can
present this as part of your Jupyter Notebook,
or Python notebook to be precise, because now
you have got a lot of different notebooks,
right? Zeppelin notebook, Jupyter, notebook vs.
Code notebook. So you can present it as notebooks,
like embed within notebook, or you can
also present it as a separate web page.
So you have the liberty for example, if you're
prototyping something on a Google collab notebook,
you can still create a radio interface within
a Google collab notebook and radio will give
you a URL which you can use to embed this
radio UI, the web application within your
Google collab notebook, which means let's say
I want to publish a paper, right? So what is
what what what is papers with code, so you try
to publish your paper with the code. But imagine
you can publish your paper, not just with code,
but also with a web interface, where people can
play around with your model, like, now, this is
going to prevent a lot of things. For example,
let us say there is a bias in your model. And then
you have no clue about the bias. But before the
model becomes mainstream, somebody plays around
with that, and then come up with the bias, like
identify the bias. And you can you can actually
see a lot of people have utilized radio to find
such biases available in image segmentation
model language, language models in the past
about a particular community. So gradient has been
already used, where biases have been identified.
The second thing is adversarial attacks, when you
have a machine learning model, you want to make
sure that you know, the models are not going to be
attacked by you know, some some silly examples or
some, like it's not prone to adversarial attacks.
So for that, you cannot make sure everything and
then you know, the community can always help you.
And for that, again, like if you have your model,
and you believe it's a very good model, you
believe it can do something good in the world,
it's, it's very important for you to make sure
what kind of adversarial attacks this model is
prone to and for somebody to actually even try
out that adversarial attack, they need something
to play with, right. And radio can be that. So
radio could be embedded within your collab code,
Google notebook, sorry, Google collab, notebook,
Jupyter notebook or any sort of Python notebook
and also as a separate web page. So you can just
take the link and then share it with anybody like
it generates a public link for you. And then you
can generate it with anybody Imagine, imagine,
like you're you're trying to attend a machine
learning interview, and you have been asked to
build a model. And then instead of just rather
giving just a model in like a pickle file, you
can actually build an interface and then share it
with your potential employer, or you're going to
go to a conference and then you want to, you want
to show something out of your machine learning.
And instead of having the machine learning model
on your PowerPoint presentation, you can also have
it as a web interface, where all the attendees
of the conference can play with so this is
enormous potential. And that's the second biggest
advantage of radio like you can present and share
radio applications within notebook outside
of notebook with anybody in the world.
Another third thing is if you
want to do permanent hosting,
like Until now we were talking about temporary
hosting, you get a you get a like a URL that is
like an ngrok URL and then you can share it with
anybody but but if you want permanent hosting,
today, you have a very good option which is called
hugging face spaces. So hugging face spaces is an
initiative from hugging face the machine learning
company that used to be the NLP company, where
you can deploy your very interface for completely
free, very easy, very simple, I've got a separate
video about that already, I can link that in the
YouTube description. But otherwise, you can also
check it out. At the end of this course we will
learn how to deploy a radio you AI radio app
on hugging face spaces like even without even
touching your local machine completely coded on
the web and also deployed deployed completely like
seamlessly and the workflow is really really easy.
So, if you want permanent hosting again you have
a very good option the form of hugging face spaces
to host your radio application now that you
are you could share it with anybody you can
I mean you you can now share it with anybody
permanently not just like a temporary interface.
So easy and fast setup, you can present and
share the radio application with anybody in
the form of notebook or web application. And
finally, you have the ability to permanently
host radio applications. These are these are
really good advantages and like I said before,
have letting people to play around with your model
has a lot of advantages. In a corporate world and
also in an academia. Oneness like I said like you
can eliminate bias you can eliminate adversarial
attacks second Like, you can actually let people
play around with something that you have built,
which is the whole point of building something,
right. So a lot of advantages of using radio,
radio has very good interface with hugging, face,
Jupyter, notebook, matplotlib, NumPy, pytorch,
scikit learn and a lot of other machine learning
libraries or scientific stack in Python. And you
can see already there are a lot of people who love
using radio, and then they have Windows radio to,
to use radio as a solution to do a lot of
things. For example, if you see the last example,
it very clearly says honestly, without radio,
we wouldn't be really doing a real time a trial.
So in clinical trials for them to try out their
algorithm, they have used radio and like without
NLP, again, somebody has used radio. And you
can you can actually see a lot of different
use cases of how people have used radio and what
are the things that people have used radio for.
So if you're interested in taking your machine
learning model, and then making a full stack
application, this course is for you. So we'll
learn more about radio in the future section.
In this section, we're going to learn how to build
our first radio application. Previously, we learnt
about why do we need radio and what is radio and
some of the advantages of radio. And so here, we
are going to start with coding. And to code, I'm
going to basically use the Getting Started page on
radio. This is quite a comprehensive page. If you
don't prefer watching a video, I would strongly
recommend you to check out this page. So to code
I'm choosing Google collab interface. So I've
created a Google collab notebook. So all you have
to do is go to go to Google and then type Google
collab, you would get an interface and you have to
go to File and click new notebook. Once you click
new notebook, you would get something like this.
And then you can change the name of the notebook.
So I've given the name here called Building your
first radio web application. Let me zoom it,
zoom it a little bit so that you can see
it. After you have all these things. You
can connect with the Google collab notebook.
Basically, Google collab notebook is Google
machine that Google gives us to practice machine
learning, like create applications, whatever,
like create scripts, whatever you want. And this
is a notebook interface hosted on Google collab.
So at this point, you can see like you have got
a machine like you have got a decent machine. And
you can see the missions usage here, like the
RAM disk, all these things. For our purpose,
you can do the same thing on your local machine as
well. You don't you don't necessarily need Google
collab. But if you need Google collab, you can
use that as well. So the first step, after you
have the Google collab interface is basically you
will have certain basic Python libraries that are
predominantly used in Python machine learning
stack for just just by default. For example,
if you want pandas, you would already have
pandas here. But if you want something that is
not available there, then you need to unity unity
install the library first. So in our case, we are
going to install CREATE VIEW. First, the first
step is installing radius. So I'm going to say,
Pip, let me delete this, I'm gonna say
pip install radius. So first step is
install the library radio. And you can you can see
that it is getting started. If you face any issue
in this, basically, all you have to do is go
here, and then just restart runtime. Yeah,
restarted runtime. After you restart runtime,
you can see the runtime gets restarted.
And after the runtime has restarted, you would see
being connected to a machine. So this, this icon
would change like from orange, so you're getting
a new machine allocated. After this allocation,
you can again install the library. So whenever you
face an issue, on Google collab, all you have to
do is go there, and then restart your runtime.
But make sure if you have anything temporary,
like a temporary variable store, when you restart
runtime, it may not be available for you. So let's
wait for the machines allocation to happen. So the
first application that we're going to build would
something look like this. So you're given him and
then it would give an output. And then I'm going
to explain you every single part of the code.
So that's going to be this particular section,
where you would get to learn the radio web
application. Once your connection is established,
you can see this here, and all you have to do
is go ahead and then install the radio library.
At this point, the radio library would get
installed. It's a very lightweight library,
so it shouldn't take a lot
of time for you to install.
So you can see that the video library
has been successfully installed.
So after the library is installed, you can you
can basically like just for the sake of sanity,
I'm going to clean my outputs. But here you can
just keep it as well or you can install it quietly
like this. So after the upgrade your libraries
installed, the next thing that we're going to
do is we're going to build our first application.
So the first thing that we have to do as in every
time Under libraries import grid view as gr, so
you're basically importing the radio library here
with the alias GL, the next thing that you have
to do is you need a function. So a radio interface
has three components of function, input and
output. So first, we need to define the function.
So let's say we're going to define a function
that says hello world, okay? Very typical
machine learning stuff, programming. So
where we are going to return saying, hello.
And probably an emoticon plus the name, the
name, okay. So this is what we are going to
do. And maybe like, if we want, we can, we can add
something to this. So this is a function if you
want to see how the function works, what you can
start doing is you can call the function and then
you know, pass on some name, maybe you can say,
to coder, and then see whether it outputs okay,
it it outputs Hello, one little quarter. So
let's, let's give some space. So that we have
this thing. So now our function is set that that
function main function that you want to create,
assume that this is your machine learning model,
right now you don't have a machine learning model.
But it's like you know, you could be you could
have a speech translation model some some machine
learning model. So now that you have got your
function, now let's start building our radio
interface. So the radio interface we want to like
you can call it anything you can like, I can just
call it interface. So I can say interface is equal
to, I can say gr dot interface. And within this,
I'm going to have three main components. One
is a function, so they just call it wait.
Yeah, one of the function, the function,
what we want to call here is hello world.
And then the second thing is an input. So
what kind of input do we want? Do we want
to capture a text input? Because that's
what we're doing here, right? So text,
and the third is output. And what kind of output
we want, we want the text output. So text input,
text output. And also what is the function.
So now let's define this interface.
Okay, hello world is not defined. It's because
I've made a stupid typo. Okay, hello world is
defined. And then we have got the interface now
that this is successfully run, the next step for
us is to launch the interface, interface launch.
And once you launch the interface, ideally, you
should be able to see the application somewhere
here. So let's wait for it to launch. So a couple
of things would happen behind the scenes. So
Google collab notebook, if you want, if you want.
If you want the notebook to show, like if you
want to debug, so you need to use debug is equal
to true while launching, you have a public URL
as well. So this link will expire in 72 hours.
So if you want, if you want longer links,
probably you need to contact radio support,
which is not required for us. And then
also like you have, you have the app. Okay,
so let's click the link, then go here and see, how
does it look like. It's loading, as you can see.
And we have the same application embedded here
as well. So we can see the same thing here as
well. So you can see that of the name, and you
have the output. So let's say I want to give
one little coder and submit this. And then you
can see Hello, and little code. If I say hello,
Python with an emoticon maybe in face emoticon,
and then submit. So you get this. So basically,
you have something you submitted. And while it is
run, you can see you can see something happening
here, click this you can see you can see that
right so you can see that this has been processed.
And then you can you can take a screenshot, if you
want to flag it, you can do do all these things.
If you want to clear this input, you can clear
this input. So these are like the basic default
options that you get with radio. But again, this
is not what integrators and the same application,
whatever, we just open with a URL. So the URL
is useful for you to share it with your friends,
and potential employer colleagues, like
whatever whoever is on the world, the planet
with internet connectivity. But if you want to
share this web application as a Google collab
notebook or Jupyter, notebook, or any notebook of
that sort, so you can still do it because if the
same thing is also embedded here, so I can go here
and then say, gradient, okay, and I can put put
some magic one. And when I click Submit, so you
can see that it has taken 0.00 seconds like very,
very minimal time. And then you can see the output
as well. And if I want to take a screenshot of
this, I can take a screenshot of this. So at this
point, we have successfully managed to build our
very first greedier web application. And in the
next section, we will learn how to improve this
web application is This is enough for let's say
computer vision problem No, this is not enough.
Is this enough? Where we need to have multiple
input option or this is not enough so the next
section we're going to learn the customizations
of different components that are available in
grid view. But at this point, you should be able
to code your very first video web application. So
congratulations to you. In this section, you're
going to learn how to customize radio components.
Which means in the last section, you learned
how to build a very simple radio application.
And this section will help you to improve or
enhance your application for your needs. So if
you remember what we learned in the last section,
a radio interface, a radio application, the
interface is a core interface class, it actually
has three main parameters. One is the function,
the function is where the input is passed on
to. And the output of the function, whatever
you're returning from the function is shown as an
output. And if you remember, that's what you have.
So you have got the input, and you have got the
output, and something goes between it that is a
function. So now we are going to learn and
finally write, of course, after you do all
these things you're going to launch. So basic, the
basic skeleton of a radio application is you have
the import statement, you have the function,
then you have the interface, then finally,
you're going to launch. Now we are going to learn
how to customize these components like input,
output, or also anything else that is available
in such a way that you can build slightly more
complex applications, because that's the whole
point, right? Nobody is going to just take
a text, and then show something. I mean, like you
can build gradle applications like that as well.
But our whole point is to do something beyond
this. And then we can see, we can learn how
grade your supports us or enables us doing that
thing. And once again, like I said in the previous
video, and basically using the material, the code
that is available in the radio documentation,
I strongly recommend you using this documentation.
So if you have any, like if you have any concern,
whatever I'm showing the video, you should
definitely refer the documentation because
that is exactly what I'm using as well. So
let us get started and then try to understand
how to customize our radio component. So
currently, our radio application looks like this.
So we have a name. And we have an output. Okay, so
there is one mean, and one output. Like right now
you can see the textbox is not very big. What have
you need a bigger textbox? With a valid question,
right. So what if you need a bigger textbox, all
you have to do is you have to create an input
component. So I'm just copying the same radio
interface that we already had. And instead of
creating a new function, I'm just going to
show you like we can keep the same function,
which is the hello world in this case, but I'm
going to show you how you can change the input. So
what we are trying to do is, we are trying to make
this input slightly bigger. And for that, we are
going to use a new component from radio, which is
radio because we have imported grade us. And here,
radio inputs. So we have inputs. And within
that you can see you have a lot of inputs,
like you have audio checkbox, data frame
drop downs, you have a lot of things. And
then the one that we are interested in is we're
going to use a text box. And the text box takes
an argument that says lines, number of lines.
So let's say we want a five line. And then we
can have a placeholder text, the placeholder
text is enter your input here to the reader.
And then we can now execute this, and then say
interface dot launch. And you should did I just,
yeah, that's mine. And then you can launch the
interface like you can see the interface. And
you can see there is a different URL altogether.
But you can launch. So now you have a bigger name.
So instead of had having a smaller name,
so if you want this to be more like a lot
bigger than you can, again, change the number of
lines, and then you can have a bigger textbox.
So this is how you can customize the input. Okay,
so you had function, we kept the same function,
you had output, we get the same output, but we
just change the input from a simple text box
like a single line text box into multi line text
box that gives us multiple lines of the code. So
this way, this is a simple example for you to
learn how to change the radio components like
how to change the radio component within the grid
application, so that you can have multiple lines
of input text given that this is a text, let
us say we don't want text. Okay. Let's say we
don't want text, but we want an image. So in the
next section, we'll learn how to build an image
input. Instead of text input, we'll learn how to
build an image input. And that image input will be
used for some kind of machine learning one second.
So for that, let's go to the radial documentation.
And there is a very nice example that that is
given. We're going to take the same example.
And then I'm going to show you I'm going to
explain you the components. So input radio's Jr,
same thing. NumPy is for image processing, we are
just going to apply a sepia filter. Okay, so we
are going to take an input image, and then we are
going to apply a sepia filter. And then that's it,
let's let's leave this function because
this is just going to apply a sepia filter.
So the most important part for us is instead
of having a text, like as in here, which is
which is here, right, instead of having a text
box, we are going to have an image as an input.
And then we are also giving the shape of the
image. Okay, and the output is also supposed to be
an image. And once you run this, you can see the,
you can see the textbox like I delete the box,
so you can click and upload it, or you can drop
down the image. So if you have downloaded the
image somewhere, then you can drop the drop down,
drop the image here, and then that will work. So
I can, I can show you a sample image. And then
we can see how it works. So I've selected an
image from my folder, and you can see the image
is available. So I'm going to click submit.
And then you can see that the sepia filter has
been applied. So basically, instead of having a
text input, you're getting an input image. And
also the output format is an image. So again,
this is not named document like if you want named
again, you can say my function is equal to this,
my input is equal to this, my output is equal to
this. But if you don't want that to happen, like
if you just want to just want to give this like in
the same model, you can do the same thing as well,
like you have the grid your interface, your
function, your input and output. And in this case,
image is not input is not text, but it is an
image. And you get that from the inputs class.
So inputs image, and then output is also image.
So we have successfully learned in this section,
we have successfully learned how to use radio two
to build an image application like an application
that takes image as an input, and also image
as an output. So now that this, this is quite
interesting, right? So we first saw text with
them. So image, but now the question is, what if
we want to work with tabular data. So in the next
section, we're going to learn how to build a radio
application that takes tabular data as an input.
And once again, like I said, we're going to refer
the radio documentation. So radio documentation
has a very nice example, where you work with
tabular data. So there is a tabular data
and that tabular data has been taken inside
and then you know, some kind of data
transformation and not not to the ETL level,
but some data transformation is happening. And
then you can see there is an input data frame.
So there is a data frame as input. So this is
again, use this for an example. But you could
you could be reading the data frame from your
CSV file, and you could be displaying as well.
But the important thing that you have to note here
is you have an input component called data frame.
So like you had text box like you had image, now
you have an input format called data frames, and
also an output. So you have like data frame as an
output, you have plot, and you have NumPy. So you
have input, and you have output, and you have the
function, and we can add a description as well.
So this is something that we have not seen before,
where we didn't see description, but we have seen
a description. So let's launch it. Once
again, it's loading. And then you can see
that you have you have an input
data frame, if you click submit,
you can see output one is a table. So you can see
you can go to the function and see it's returning
three things. One, you are returning a tabular
data frame, second, you are returning a plot.
And third, you're returning a numpy array.
So you have an output, you have a plot,
and then you have a numpy array. So if you
want to change the value, again, like go ahead
and change something around it. And then you would
see like, again, ideally, in an ideal world, you
will not define the data frame asset is probably
you would be loading a CSV file or something.
And that's what like when you load a CSV file, if
you have a different value, click Submit. And then
you have three outputs output one, output two,
output three, so you have three outputs. If you
again, if you want to change it, let's say like
you don't want the outputs, you just want a plot,
we can go here, delete whatever we are returning,
and then we can come back here also delete the
output format. So we have only plot here and then
run this again. When you want to run this thing,
you would have only the input and output. And then
once I click submit, you can see the output chart
itself. So again, you are not specifying where
the output should be shown. So if you had noticed,
when we had more than one input, sorry, when we
had more than one output radio itself managed to
display output one by one, but typically if you're
building an application using any other existing
tool, so you have to manage that you have to
manage how this search so on, you have to manage
whether it is responsible or not. But here you
don't have to be worried about it. Once again.
You have the output here, if you want to change,
then you can change. Again, like we saw before,
if you want to take a screenshot, you can take a
screenshot, or right click and save the image like
whatever you want to do, you can basically do and
this is how exactly, you have an input data frame,
you have an input data frame, and you have
an output plot as a chart. Okay, so so far,
in the previous sections, we have learned input
text, input, image. And now we learned about input
data frame. And that's quite helpful. So these
these are the three main formats that typically
a data scientist or machine learning engineer
would be using. Again, you can have audio, right,
so the potential is enormous like you if you want
audio, all you have to do is go here, let's say
inputs. And you can see you can see audio. So
you can have audio, like you can have audio and
lot other things. But if you ask, like a typical
machine learning engineer, or a data scientist,
image, text, and these are like a few valuable
with me, a few valuable things, a few valuable
formats, tabular format, image and date stuff, few
valuable formats, typically, data centers, machine
learnings, use a lot. So we have learned how
to create a radio application text application,
how to create a great year image application
and also how to create a radio application
that takes a tabular data has an input. So now
we have explored different components like image,
text and tab, data frame. The next
section, we are going to learn
how to use this different components and also have
different kinds of input. And more than that. So
let's see in the next section, how to use multiple
inputs and outputs in your radio application.
So far, in the previous sections, we learned
how to build a simple radial web application.
We also learned about customizing components
like different formats, exploring different
formats like image, text, and tabular data. So
in this section, we are going to learn how to use
multiple inputs, not different types of inputs,
but multiple inputs. So not every time you want to
use only the same input, right. So for example,
if you see here, you have one text box, if you
see this example, you have a bigger text box. And
if you see this example, you have got one image.
But what if you are in a situation where you
need to take multiple input from the user,
and you want to process it in such a way and then
give some output. So for that, what we're going to
do is, we're going to make a simple function, just
like a Hello World example. And then we are also
going to learn how to handle multiple inputs in
a grid your application. Once again, like I say,
in every section, you can always explore the
documentation for this part. And it is quite
comprehensive. And the examples that I've taken
for this code is again from the documentation.
So let's start from scratch. If you have not even
you know, seeing that, whatever we did before,
so we are importing radius, Jia. So that part
is done. So the next thing is we need to create
a function, we need to create a function that can
do something. So what we can do in this case is
we can say let's calculate BMI, okay? I don't, I
don't necessarily know the formula for BMI, but
I'm just going to take a short BMI. And let's say
we want to take BMI for a person. And then we want
to take height, and then we want to take weight,
okay. And then we are going to calculate BMI now,
so and then we are going to also thank the person
based on the BMI. So the first thing that we
need to do is, let's get the BMI calculation, BMI
formula, let's say and then okay, basically it is
weight divided by height square, and the
height should be in kilograms, the weight
should be in kilograms, and the height should
be in meters. So what we can do is we can say,
Okay, first let's do the formula. And
then we can we can have a description.
So BMI is equal to BMI, Val is equal to
height, weight, divided by height squared.
Okay, use the parentheses so that you don't
have confusion about anything. So now that at
this step, we are calculating BMI. So we're going
to say, print. And then we're going to say hello.
And the name of the person, which
is in this case is name less,
some thing and a new line and your BMI is and then
you're going to say str of BMI. Okay, let's run
the function. Oh, I didn't return anything, right.
So I should have ideally return this return this.
Let's run this and then try to give the
value so I'm going to say one little quarter,
and the value which is 220. And then wait
Let's say 15. And the BMI is point 334. I
have definitely missed up this formula, which
is kilogram weight divided by height square. And
height should be in meters. right height should
be in meters in the sense. One point, centimeters.
Okay, 1.2 Maybe. Yeah, so we have got a BMI. So
approximately our formula works fine. So that BMI
participation. So the next important step for us
to do is, so make sure that you have three inputs,
and one output, right? So if you want two
outputs, we can still do that. But right now
we are exploring only one output. So what we're
going to do now is we're going to say, okay,
interface is equal to radio interface of, and
then we're going to say, function is equal to BMI,
that that part is simple inputs is equal to,
what are the inputs we want. The first thing
that we want is a text input. The second thing
we want is a checkbox. The second thing is,
let's say in this case, slider, maybe gr dot
inputs, dot slider. And the slider value goes from
zero to, let's say, 100. And the label
if you want to add a label, say height.
Okay, and then you're going to have another
slider. And this slider is for weight
in kg, and height in meters. Okay. And this should
be ID 200, I think, yep. Now this is done. The
next thing is we need to define the output.
And the output in this case is a simple text,
we are not dealing with multiple items. So simple
text should be fine. Define this. It's worked.
Now interface dot launch. So technically,
you can actually do launch here also, like,
if you want to like if you don't want to define
the interface in a separate step, you can do that.
But yeah, just just for the sake of explicitly,
I'm just doing it here. And then I'm going to
launch it. Once we launch it again, the same
thing happens where it says like debugging is
equal to true like all the same examples. So I've
got a name, let's say name is one little coder.
And then height is somewhere like this. Weight is
somewhere like this. Weight and kilogram height,
as let's see here, and then submit, you can see
that the BMI has been calculated, like forget
about what the formula is doing right now, at
this point, maybe what we can do is it looks
really ugly for us to show this thing, so maybe we
can round it off, then we have to input okay, I'm
not not dealing with rounding off at this point.
So you have Hello, the name, BMI and then the
value. So at this point, you can see that we have
successfully managed to get three inputs. And then
we are also outputting one output. But what if you
suddenly think okay, instead of just having three
inputs, let me have one more extra output, okay.
And now probably the output is something like
a emoticon. Okay, if the BMI is less than
this, let's say there is any more Deacon the
BMI is greater than this return to the remote
icon. So result emoticon. emoticon is equal to,
again, for simplicity. We can we can use
or I can I can actually actually use this.
Okay, so just use happy face.
If BMI while is less than, like maybe 30 I don't
I don't know. So don't take health advice from
this. Otherwise, keep a sad face. How do I keep a
sad face this is a sad face. This is a sad face.
So now we have a result emoticon. So now what you
can do is you can result this emoticon as well
as part of this. So we have one, okay, we have
one entire string if you want to make it easier,
you can see output string is equal to this.
Okay, and then you have the emoticons so I'm
going to say output string. And then result emoji
icon. And then I'm going to run this function.
I'm going to call the function to see okay, so
my my BMI is terrible. So it's just giving me
this sad option. So now I can come back again and
then specify that my first output is a txt. Again,
I want to do txt for the second output as well
very good. If you want a different output, you
can still do it. But in my case I want text output
as well. So run it come back here launch it again.
And once you launch it is going to give you
the application and then you can see okay,
name is let's let's say Mars, maybe hide. A
good mom. and weight is 58 Something submitted.
And then you can see, it's a happy face. The
reason we have a happy face is primarily because
the BMI is less than 30. So if I go back to
the same example, like for example, I should
be in meters, right? I should have ideally
divided this because height isn't centimeters,
let me add centimeters, and then divide the height
by two, I 100. Run this, and then try the code
and try the code on getting okay, it's because of
order of precedents, my code is getting Messier
with all the parenthesis but that's okay. So
now, I have defined height and centimeters
weight in kilograms and come back and launch
it again. Then maybe this time, we can say
Mars and Jupiter, other names. Height in
centimeters, okay, I didn't give centimeters.
It didn't get updated with this, okay? submitted.
Okay, the app did not refresh one last
time. Let's refresh this. Launch ID.
And identity because here, one little
quarter, height and centimeters on 60.
And then when you say BMI is 32, and you're sad,
and your BMI is less. Okay, you're still sad.
Okay, let's reduce the weight. And then
ideally, now you're happy because your
BMI is less than 30. So technically,
we have managed to build an application
with two outputs. Again, if you want to change
the name of the output, again, that's something
that you can change within your output as well. So
basically, what we have managed to do here is if
taken multiple inputs, and we have done multiple
outputs. And this is this is quite important,
because in a lot of cases, for example, let's say
you're doing doing neural style transfer, usually,
for neural style transfer, you would have multiple
outputs, sorry, multiple inputs and one output.
So you need to know how to do multiple inputs
and multiple outputs. And that's quite simple.
You have to match the number of arguments that
you're getting in your function with a number
of inputs, and all you have to do is the type of
input. So one of your input could be a slider,
one of your input could be text, another input
could be a number, another input input could be
an image. So you can you can have these multiple
formats as well, which is not just, you know,
like numbers and all these things. Like for
example, let's say like, suddenly we are deciding
that we want to add a checkbox, okay. And I
want to I want to add something new. So that is
feeling okay. And based on feeling I wanted to
say something, okay, so we'll say if feeling this
true, okay, then, then we'll do text is equal to
happy. Yeah, and we're going to send feeling also,
sorry, text, we have to send the text. Okay, now
this one, I'm going to make a Boolean out of it.
Okay, and how do we make a Boolean out of it
or a checkbox. So my last attribute here is
gr dot inputs dot check. The check box is checkbox
and you can see when I want to make a checkbox,
I have to specify default is false, right default
is false and the label is your feeling today
and then everything else is fine. So we have
the text as well. So we have a third text and it
ran the function again and then launch it. Now
at this point, technically, you should have one
extra check box. So check box is selected
something something height weight selected,
that is an error. There is an error and
what is the error Okay, so we have got
three inputs 1234 Our four inputs 1234
Okay, I think the problem is because
if get let me let me even do this
text is equal to if feeling is sad, okay.
And let me run this and then try with this.
So we have one 12341234. Okay, that's done.
And then let's run this, let's launch.
And then let's see this thing. So let's see
if we can if we can get rid of the error
successfully worked, right, so you have
output one, output two, output three.
And then you can disable the feeling, and then run
it again, you get sad. So basically manage to add
a new type of input without any problem. So you
have multiple types of input, multiple formats of
input, and also multiple formats and types of
output that this done. So because we have got
a bug, maybe this is a very good opportunity
for us to try. Try out the debugging option.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to
make the same mistake that we did before.
And the mistake was just using like this, right,
so this was a mistake that we had. And there is
a way for you First, identify using this, for
example, we can we can do like this. But if it
is false, it would probably throw an error like
you can see the error. But but let's forget this
kind of debugging for a moment. And then let's see
if we can find a way to debug here. So what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say debug is equal to
true. And the launch date here. They did just say,
okay, sorry, I have to add debug
is equal to launch. So that was
silly of me. So I'm going to do debug is equal to
launch. When I do the same, it's going to launch
with the debugging option. Ok. So it says this,
this cell will run indefinitely, so that you can
see the errors and logs. So if you want to turn
it off, again, you have to go back and then say
debug is equal to false. So what we are going
to do now is we are going to say something,
and then we are going to select some value, select
some value, and then click. So your, your value is
good. So you have got all output, the problem
arises when you have false value. When you
submit now, there is an error. Okay, so you
can see that there is an error. Now that error,
because we have enabled debugging mode, that
error is displayed here, which wouldn't have been
displayed otherwise. So now you can see the error
local variable text referenced before assignment.
So which means saying it gets the same error that
you would get when you're doing like a ripple
or interactive environment. So this will, again
help you to debug, so I've just taken the liberty
of making a mistake to explain you that this is
there. So all I can do is I can just add an else
or I can just go with list comprehension. Then
fix this, and come back again in debugging mode.
Right? Come back again, in debugging mode do
interface. And you can see all these are not
running because this launcher still running.
So I'm going to stop it, everything has ran,
and then run this again, then try this out.
But now the debugging mode is still true.
So you have the mode set. True is happy done.
And false is error. Again, because this because
because we didn't run it. So ideally, you
understand the point. The point here is,
once you once you've, once you have a mistake
or a bug or an error, it's very important for
you to debug it the same interface that
you have, you don't want to you know,
juggle between lots of different interfaces.
So the easiest option for you to do that is
debug is equal to true. So once you do debug is
equal to true, then you will be able to debug the
file. So we'll have a slightly extended debug
session in the next section. But if you simply
want to debug this is your way to debug. So in
this section, we just learned how to improve
your gradle web application with multiple inputs,
multiple outputs, same format, different format.
And we also played around with a bunch of
options for us to see how it works. And we
also made a deliberate mistake to understand how
do we go about debugging. So in the next section,
we'll also learn a slight extension of how
more to debug or log what is happening there.
This section, we're going to know a little bit
more about debugging your radio web application.
And also, radio has a nice feature called
flagging. And we are going to look more into that.
First, let's start with debugging in the previous
section at the end, you might have seen that we
try to debug. So extending that we're going
to see what kind of errors that we might face
and then some debugging options that we have.
The first thing that you need to make sure
whenever you are building your radio application
is that the function that you are using for your
radio application, the number of arguments in
your function should be equal to the number of
elements in your inputs. And also the number
of arguments or number of items that you are
returning should be equal to the number of items
or elements in your output. So the first thing
very important thing that you need to make
sure that it is right. The second thing is
the type of the argument For example, here name
is a text, make sure they input his text. Here,
if you have an output text, again, make sure that
it is an output text. So whatever the type is,
make sure it is that type so that you know, you
know the types have not messed up, because you're
not going to compile anything and check. So it's
always good to have you have this validation,
like, if you're creating a checklist of test
cases, this is something that you should do.
And let's say that you have, you have done
all these things, right. And then you have
built an application. But still, if you want to
validate whether your application has any error,
and this is how you have to debug it.
And the way if you want to debug this,
basically you have to enable debug is equal to
two. So debug is equal to true is just a function,
like an extra argument that will help you enable
display error messages. If you want error messages
to be displayed while the radio application is
run, which is like which is linked to run without
stopping, then you need the need to enable
debugging, like debug is equal to true.
So let me quickly give you an example. And
then we'll move on to the next section.
So if you see this thing, for example, here, we
have got height and weight and feeling right. So
by default, let's say if I don't have debug is
equal to true. Okay, I have this thing here.
I'm going to give some name, right? And then I'm
going to have something here. And if I submit,
it worked, but let's say if I keep it
like this and submit you see an error.
Now do you know why this error is happening?
Now, of course, you wouldn't know why this
error is happening, even though like probably,
if you're a math whiz, you would have probably
predicted by this time, but yeah, let's assume
that you are an average programmer. So you don't
know why the error is happening. And that's
why it's important for us to enable debugging,
like this. And then after we do that, so it says
the sale will indefinitely run like we saw before.
So it's going to run all the time, so that you can
try a lot of different things. And then you have
the error log in place. So now I'm going to do
the same thing, I'm going to put the name and then
keep it zero, keep it zero, and then submit. So it
shows error, the moment it shows error is going to
also show the error message. And the error message
here is zero division error. So float division
error. So basically what has happened here is that
this is a thing that you wouldn't have probably
anticipated when you created this application,
because now you're dividing weight by height, and
then height cannot be zero, because you're going
to get divisible by zero error. And what is the
ideal solution, you can you can go to your code,
you can change everything, you can handle the
test conditions. Or if you want to simply make a
change, you can just come back here in the slider,
you can start with one so that your user can
never go to zero. So let's run this and run this.
And now again, most likely, you are starting
with one. So even if somebody submits something,
there is no way that they're going to
hit zero in this case. So this is again,
a very typical example of how do you find out an
error and then fix an error using RADIUS debugging
method. So if you want the debugging method to be
enabled, and a lot of other things. So basically
the same way you debug your Python programming
code, so you can debug your radio application in
a very similar way, with debug is equal to true
enabled while you're launching the application.
Now that is said. So the other important
thing that I just talked about is flag. I
just told the start of the section, that flag is
another very interesting case. So what is flag,
the flag is a button that helps you flag any
erroneous or unexpected behavior, the output. So
you could be running a model and then suddenly you
see something weird. You can use flag, you could
you could have like let's say my segmentation
model, and then you're trying to find out
which images have done well, which images have not
done well. So you can just click flag, whenever
you see the images have not done well. And you
could you could use this for a lot of purpose.
But what happens when you click flag? That's
the most important question, right? Let's say
you have an internal machine learning team and you
have created an application and given it to them.
And that team whenever they find out something,
we are some, let's say some bias some something
unexpected happening in the model behavior or even
this calculation, something weird is happening,
right? So now we want to flag the team that
has created this application. So what does it
mean? What does the team see when we create flag
here? So let's do a couple of flags. And I'll let
you know. So first, there is a flag. So let's do
one more thing. And then we'll say another flag.
Okay, so we have flagged at this point, we have
flagged two items in this case. So now what
happens here is when you create flag, ideally
there is a flagged folder that gets created. So
I've stopped it and then if I go back, there is a
flagged folder. So when when we go to the folders,
let me refresh the folder. And you can see there
is a flagged folder and there is a lock here.
Let me copy the path of this folder. Come back
here and then use pandas to show you what is there
import pandas as PD. PD dot read underscore CSV
the path. And then you can see the instances,
you can see the instances, what is the
name? What are the inputs that were given?
And what was the output. And these are flagged.
So this is to help the machine learning team
or ml ops team, whatever the team that
is going to look into the model issues
to check, what are the items that are flagged by
the users or internal testing or whatever that is,
right. So whenever you flag something, there is a
new entry that is made here. And, and that entry
is used in the future, to evaluate the model or
the performance of the application. So right now,
what you saw is an application that just had
text. So now what happens when you have images,
what happens when you have images, right? For
example, we had we had an application like this,
what happens when you have an image like this,
when you have an application that has images,
both the input and output images gets stored,
unlike this, where you have text, where you have
everything in tabular data only, and you don't
have anything else, right, so if you go to the
folder, you wouldn't see anything else other than
dot CSV. But when you have images, the actual
images or any other media type for that matter,
the actual media content itself is stored inside
that follows making it easier for you to evaluate
what has gone wrong. This is a very important
aspect. Again, when you're going to use gradient
for retraining your machine learning model or
improving your machine learning model, this is
quite important and useful to us. And again, a lot
of people who build radio might not be very aware
of this thing, because you know, just exist there.
But yeah, efficiently using flag can improve your
machine learning model can help you identify,
there is a bias. Like for example, let's say you
put together a machine learning model. And then
you've created a radio wave application, you have
a published data hugging face basis or somewhere,
you can explicitly tell your users saying that
if you find anything interesting or weird,
then please go ahead and click flag because
that will help us improve the model, eliminate
the biases, or you know, be more robust. So you
can tell this explicitly in the description that
you have a description right like you, you can
like you can write a description here like this.
And then flag if you find any erroneous output,
okay, so I can run this. And then I can let me
disable it. And then it can run when it runs
it descriptor flag, any flag if you find any
erroneous or put some having this message
very clearly as part of the application
could help people understand that when they
see something wrong, they have to flag and that
comes to you as a very well structured
data which you can use in the future,
to fix your machine learning model or do
anything that you want to do with the data. So
one aspect of debugging in radio is actually
you know, using the debug is equal to true.
But I'm also including this in this section,
because I believe that if you our machine learning
model doesn't work well. If your machine learning
model is doing something semantically wrong,
not syntactically but semantically wrong. Only
the user who is actually seeing the output can
tell you that thing and that human intervention
could be made, the flag could be raised using
this flag button. And that could be extremely
useful in a lot of different cases. One thing that
you would want to note when you're talking about
flaggers. So right now the flag content is in the
the actual folder, like the current folder, but
if you want it to be in a different folder, then
you have a flagging directory. So you can have
a separate directory, you can specify a separate
flagging directory. And that will probably enable
you to have this flagging, like flagged content in
a different directory altogether if you want it
to be in a different directory. But otherwise,
everything is good here flagging is extremely
helpful. This is how you do debugging. And
these are some things that you
should pay more attention to.
And in the next section, we will learn some
quirks and nuances about radio application.
So far, we have learned all basic and
very important things about building a
radio application. So in this section, we're
going to learn how to enhance or improve your
existing radio application that looks better
that does better It has better user experience.
And to start with, we are going to talk
about examples in radio application.
So what is examples? For example, if you have
a radio application that looks like this,
sometimes the user might get confused. What
do I have to give here? What do I have to do
here? What do I have to do here? And to avoid this
confusion, usually in user experience, if you see
a lot of existing tools, like I can quickly show
you a tool that I came across recently, which is
called shield or how when you go here, it's still
loading. But when you see this thing you can see
there are suggested commands. So these are like
examples. So instead of somebody trying to figure
out what to type here, a good user experience
would always be very intuitive where people can
just click And then select it. In a very similar
user experience. Principle, radio also has got
something called examples. And I'm going to show
you how to do examples in this section right now.
So let's start with the example. An example is
quite easy. What do you want to do with example,
for all the input, you're meant to give an
example value. So I'm going to come here,
and then say, after output, I'm going to say
examples. Okay, and here, I'm going to just,
I'm going to select what all examples I'm going
to give there. Like the the previous examples are
nothing but predefined answers. So I'm going to
have a list. And within that, I'm going to have
another one. And the first one is, let's say, one
little coder name. And then the second one is,
let's say 100. And the third one is, let's say
50. And then the fourth one is true. Okay, so this
is one example. The next one, I'm going to copy,
let's say, Mars 120 3020. Yeah. And third example,
like, we will stick to three examples, let's
say moon, and then 200. Or maybe we can use u
and Moon. Under third 150 kilos,
and then false. So we have three examples. Now
when we run this application, invalid syntax.
Because we didn't add the commodity, that's
why it's invalid syntax. When we launched this
application, at this point, you would see this
application being launched with examples. So
you can see, there are three examples. So when you
have a great new application that looks like this,
if you don't know like, let me even open this
video application separately, so that it's easier
for us to see. So when we have this great new
application, it might be difficult at first for
somebody to know what to fill. So what they can
do is we have examples, all I have to do is click
this application, and then submit, then they will
get the output, click this example, click Submit,
and then give the output. So it becomes very easy
for anybody to click something and then get an
output rather than themselves typing something. So
this is very important for a very intuitive user
experience. And thanks to gray area for offering
this because this is what a lot of good web
applications, especially to give intuitive user
interfaces. So whatever the type is, like if you
have an image, you can give image as an example,
if you have tabular data just like us like not
tabular data necessarily, but text and numerical
data and Boolean values, you can have this. So
for whatever type of data that you have, you can
specify examples. Very simply, just by defining
another parameter here that takes different list.
Like you have multiple lists multiple examples,
you don't want to also give like 1020 Different
examples, examples should be like one or two.
In this case, we have taken three examples.
So example is a very, very important way for
us to improve the user experience of the radio
application. So that is one important thing. So
you need to know when to use example, and how to
use example. And that's what you just learned.
The second thing is, what if you don't want to
click submit all the time, what if you want it to
be reactive, so if you have seen stream late,
if you have seen are shiny, or if you have seen
even Tableau, like there are a couple of instances
where you can select an option, and then suddenly,
it is reactive. So certainly you would see the
output rather than somebody going and clicking.
And for that, within this, like within the greater
interface, you have an argument called life.
If you say live is equal to true currently, by
default, live is equal to false. If you say life
is equal to true, then you don't have to submit
every time. And that's what we're going to see
now. I'm going to disable the exam. Okay, let
me keep the examples and say, life is equal to
true, right? And then let's run it. And
let's run it again. Is it going to restart,
imagine? So I have this thing here, right? I have
this thing here. But you can see that there is no
submit button at this point. So submit button
is gone, because it's live. So all I have to do
is I can go here and then select it. And then
you can see the output. I have to go here and
let me zoom out a little bit. Yeah, all I have to
do is go here, select it, you can see the output,
I can go here selected, you can see the output
selected, you can see the output. So basically,
you are eliminating one extra step. So this is
useful in some situations, not in some situations.
For example, if you have a situation
where model inference takes a lot of time,
then you wouldn't want this to happen. Because if
somebody like by mistake, click something silly,
no good start processing. So you would want that
explicit submit button in those kinds of cases.
In cases where you like, for example, this case,
right? We don't necessarily want somebody to
click Submit. In cases like this, you can like for
example, you change the slider, it would it would
change. So in cases like this, this makes sense.
But in some other cases, it may not make sense.
But live radio application is another useful
feature because it again improves user experience
with a submit explicit submit action button
action is not required. So if you think an
explicit action, like submit is not required,
then you can then then you can actually have,
then then you can actually have this thing
in place, which is a live application. So,
the next way to improve user experience
is we discussed in the previous section
about flagging. So, flagging can also
have multiple options. For example,
instead of just simple flagging, we can say
flagging options, equal to, so we can say, is no,
maybe something like that, okay, and then run
it and run it. And now when you run this thing,
you can actually see flagging options. So you
instead of like, for example, let me click this
thing, and you have three flagging options, all
you have to do is hover your mouse on it, you have
three flagging options. So as you know, maybe,
and these things, these values might also get
recorded. So flagging again, instead of keeping
a simple plugin, for example, let's say you want
to build a text annotation, some, like simple
annotation tool. So now all you have to do is
like you can have all your entities here. And then
you can ask somebody to annotate. So as simple as
that, even if you have a major whatever that is,
or maybe like a prediction is right or wrong or
not, right, so you can again, use this to
actually do unit testing under flag flag,
not only when something goes wrong, but also you
can use this to kind of label things on the go
while you're building your machine learning model.
Again, flagging options is extremely helpful,
because you can use it for something more
than what flagging is supposed to do.
So flagging is very, very helpful. So far,
we have seen examples. So far we have seen
live application. And also we have, we have
seen different options in flagging. The final
thing that I wanted to highlight here, which
I'm not going to show you right now is using a
state. So what is the state? Let me quickly
show you state here. Radio getting started.
I'm going to copy the example from radio page.
So what is the state? So one thing that you know,
very clearly is that every time you
click Submit in your grading application,
the entire app resets. That's, I
think that's something that we all can
agree. There is no persistence of data here. So
anytime you submit something, the data is reset.
What if you want to have persistence of data? What
if you want to use a data point or a data from the
previous before submitting to the next instance.
And that's where state comes into picture. And
state is quite common, again, in full stack
development. So if you want to create a state
that persists outside of a single function
call, which means you need a global variable,
right? So you need something that is outside this
function like outside the function that you have
this function, if you want, if you have a use case
like that, then you need to set state and the chat
message is a typical example, right? Why chat
messages, a typical example, somebody says hello,
and then you replay Hello. And somebody says,
How are you, you will say I'm fine. Now in the
application, you want all these messages to be
there, you don't want every time to you know,
initialize with empty message, because you want
the previous data to be there. And that is where
state is quite helpful, because you want the data
to persist across multiple submits. Okay, so let's
look at this demo quickly. And then we can see
how it works. So quickly see the demo of state.
I'm running this thing. And again, like I said
before, this is an example straight out of
radio documentation. So messages,
hello. And then I'm going to submit it,
you can say hello. So it says, the next message
is, how are you? And then I can see how are you
okay, you can see the response, you can see the
response here, right? So and this is important,
because you want that message to persist as
well. So that's why state is very important.
And you can refer data, I'm not getting
deep into it, because that is again,
a topic for a separate, you know, Section
altogether. So to avoid that, I'm just saying that
you can go to the Get Started page in radio. Also,
you can check in the documentation about state.
So this is what the purpose of status to have
something beyond the function like to create
like a global variable or to the function call,
so that even when you when you load this thing,
it doesn't there is persistence. And the very best
use case that you can think of is you want to load
a large model. And every time you want to load the
model, you don't want it to be refreshed if you
have if you have the model being loaded inside In
this, you don't want it to get refreshed all the
time. So you want to load the model outside the
function. And then inside the function you do,
everything gets like inference, right. So. So that
is a very good use case and states could be used
there. So explore state more. And that could be
really, really helpful for you in improving your
radio application. So, if you need a variable that
should be persistent outside the function call,
then set state is the function that you should
set state and get state is a function that you
should be looking at, to store and retrieve
the persistent data that you have created.
So that is state and the final state then. So
we have seen examples, we have seen live radio.
And we have seen state. And the very final thing
that I want to talk about improving your radio
application is grid, your themes, and grid,
your CSS. So grid your application by default,
you would see something that looks
like this, I'm going to remove,
I'm going to remove the flagging options,
I'm going to remove the description,
I'm going to even remove the live option, okay.
So by default, you would see the radio application
that looks orangish, which is in line with that
radio color. But but sometimes you want something
else, right? So sometimes you want to, you want
to try something else, like you want a different
color combination, you want a different thing.
So Gradle has two options for that for you. One
gradient has got seen so quickly showing
theme. So you have the default option,
you have hugging face option, you have
grass option, peach option, dark option.
So you have got different themes. The second
one is rather than using the existing theme,
the theme that is available on all these themes,
you yourself can actually create custom CSS.
So you can use custom CSS option to create theme.
And that is again, another important feature if
you want to try out something. So we are going
to explore these two options now. So theme and
custom CSS. First, let's start with theme. So I
have a Grady obligation that looks like this. And
maybe you know what I can I can do side by side.
It doesn't it doesn't let me do side by side.
Okay, I thought I can just show it side by side.
It doesn't allow me to do that. That's okay. So
first thing that I want to do is I want to enable
a theme. Okay. So theme of theme is equal to what
is the theme name? Let's start with the hugging
phase. And then we'll go to some dark theme. And
I run this thing and run this, you would see the
theme color changing. It's you can see. Now the
theme theme has changed. Like it's an this is the
hugging face theme. Right? So it's cleaner. And I
would actually say like it's cleaner if you want
no no offense to existing default Dario theme,
but yeah, it's it's cleaner. If you want a
different theme, let's say like you want a
dark theme, then you can just go like dog beach,
or dog default. Maybe we can do doc freaking face.
Let's let's try how it looks. Doc. Okay, and
this and this, and then see how does it look?
Well, this is quite nice. This is again, a very
pleasant dark theme. So you can you can see the
font is white in color. You select something, you
submit something, you have everything in Word in
color. So this way you can play around with the
theme, right hugging face thing, let us say you
have played around with this thing. But there
is one thing that you don't like necessarily,
and you want to change that. And that's where your
CSS is going to help. So one thing that you can
do with CSS is you can for example, let's say you
want to change the background color to something.
So I can go here, say CSS is equal to and
then I can I can add the CSS, I'm going to use
multi lines just to keep it easy for me. And
then I'm going to say background color. This
Okay, let's run this, run this. And then you
would see the change in the color. Ideally,
it didn't change. Okay, let me
disable the theme. And then see.
You can see after I disable the team because
the team overrides the CSS. So after you
disable the theme, you can see the color of the
background has changed. Like if you want to, let's
say like a different color altogether.
Let's say you want you want, let's say,
yellow, maybe terrible option.
But again, just for demo purposes.
If you want a background color to be a low
end color, you can you can again change it.
In the previous section, we learned how to
improve the user interface and user experience
of our radio web application. So we learned
about examples. We learned about life mode.
We also learned a little bit about state and then
finally we learned about themes and CSS custom CSS
to redesign our Radio web application. In this
section we are going to learn how to share the
radio application with anybody in the world. And
also the most important aspect is do you want
everybody to see that? Or do you want to add an
authentication page before anybody could access
your radio application. So the first thing is, by
default, when you launch your 3d application, you
would get a URL like this, and that that URL stays
for 72 hours. So you can get this URL, and then
share it with everybody, anybody in the world. And
then they can use the URL for 72 hours. But if you
want to make it explicit, there is an attribute
called share. So if I say shared is equal to true,
whether to create a publicly shareable link from
your interface, so you can say share is equal to
true. And that will also give you the same
URL if you want. And then the next thing is,
you don't have to only share the app. But
also you have the ability to share the APA,
which is something that not a lot of people
who do so APs are very helpful. For example,
if you want to integrate this, let's say you
have a JavaScript based stack available, and you
want to integrate this machine learning solution
inside JavaScript based solution, the easiest way
for you to do is to use an APA. So what Grady also
gives you is the APA with also some starter code.
So for example, the A for this particular
app, when I click this view, the APA you
can see that there is an APA here, and then that
APA says like this interface takes four inputs,
returns three outputs, the URL endpoint, you can
copy. And these are the input types. These are the
output types. This is how the payload is going to
look like. And this is how your response is going
to be. And also you have couple of examples where
you have a Python code, you have a curl code,
and you have a JavaScript code. So if you want to
check it, you can go here, and then click Post,
and then you would get the response yours. Or if
you want to try it on your Google collab as well,
you can come back here and this and then
say, okay, okay, true, we have to say true.
And then see if you have the outputs or the time
it took the data input, sorry, the data output,
and then again, the time it took. So if you
have multiple calls, then you can see the
average time otherwise, it would mean the same.
So basically, not just the app that you can share
with the world. But you can also share the API
where anybody can make a call to the endpoint,
and then get the result that they want.
Instead of saying get the result should say,
post the response, post the request, then get the
response. Yeah, whatever it is. So one, take this
link, share the link with anybody, they would be
able to access the app, second, add slash APA, or
the EPA link that you can get from here, and then
share it with anybody, they can use it the second,
now that we know how to share a radio
application with the entire world.
The next important thing is, do you want to share
it just like that, or you want to share it with
an authentication page. So now we are going to
learn how to add an authentication page on top of
a radio application. So basically, when somebody
clicks this link, it makes sure you're listening.
So basically, when somebody clicks this link, we
don't want them to directly see this app, we don't
want anybody in the world to see this app. But we
want one least specific people who have access to
this application. So maybe let's say I have
generated a username and password and given to
them, I want to only them to use this application.
So if you want to add an authentication page,
what are we going to do, and that is quite
easy and simple unexpectedly, usually,
adding an authentication page could be another
overhead. But it is extremely simple here because
all you have to do is when you're going to
launch the application, all you have to do
is you have to give up. And also if you want
any if you want to write only if you want any
HTML message on the authentication page.
So I'm going to show you how it works.
First, let's start with an authentication page. A
simple authentication page, I'm going to say odd,
is equal to, I'm going to add a username password.
So basically, I'm going to do like this A tupple
username, password, and the user name here. Let's
say I'm going to say user. And then the password
I'm going to say is one little code. Okay, so this
is the username, this is the password. Okay, I'm
going to run this. After I run this thing. I have
got the app. So I'm going to click the link here.
And you can see it takes us to an authentication
page. Let's say I'm going to give a wrong
username password first. I'm going to say user
and the password, I'm going to say something else.
And when I do that, it says the server could not
verify you, you either supplied wrong credential,
or your browser doesn't understand how to
supply the credential. So the first thing is,
it works. It works. The authentication works. It's
not letting anybody to log in. So now let's try
I'm going to give one little coded. And then
you can see it has successfully taken us into
the application. So basically, we have managed to
add an authentication page on top of our radio UI,
just purely with one single argument.
So added a value username password to
auth argument. And then we have managed to add
a login page. So let's refresh this, you can see
this because we have already authenticated. So
let's run this again. And I wanted to show you
an extra thing. So when you run this thing, when
you go here and see this thing, you can see the
login page does not have much details. Let's say
you have shared the login details to somebody in
the email. And you want to make this in the
login page itself. So that is where you have
an auto message. So I can say odd message.
We can say check your strong login details.
Strong sent to your email. So we can
see email. And if you want to add,
add an emoticon you can probably add an emoticon.
So now you're hiding a login message also along
with the usual authentication page. And, like
authentication message also. So let me click this,
go here. And then say it says, check
your login details into your email,
and you have this thing. So this way people would
know that they have to look at their Slack channel
or an email or discord or whatever it is, so that
they actually know where the email is, once again,
let's let's just log in one little corridor. And
then try, we have successfully managed to login.
So this is how it is quite easy and simple for
you to add an authentication page to your ad
application. And, and it's quite simple. So all
you need to do is you can give a tupple. Or also
you have another option. So you can either
give like, like username, password topple.
Or you can you can take in different formats also
like if you want or you can have a function also
like that takes username and password
and then you know, validate something,
and then returns true if there is like the valid
authentication, like let's say you have a dB,
you don't want to just give hard coded values,
then you can do all those things. And also you
have the ability to provide an authentication
message along with the login authentication page.
So this basically takes us to the end of building
a radio web application. But this course does
not end here. We want to also deploy the radio
application. So for what we have done here, as we
have managed to deploy the radio APPLICATION make
it available on the collab interface with radio
link. But can you deploy this radio application
on a post permanent hosting, and we are going
to see in the next section, how to deploy a
radio application using hugging face spaces.
This is the last section of this course.
And if you have made till this section,
congratulations, you have almost done
something that nobody usually does.
So in this final video, we are going to
learn how to deploy a machine learning radio
application permanently on hugging face spaces.
So the first question that you might have is,
why couldn't we have done whatever we were
doing already as something permanently. So if
you see this thing, this link, whatever you
share, it is applicable only for 72 hours,
and the interface has to run. So after 72 hours,
you might not get it then you have to rerun it
and then the URL might change you have a lot of
these complexities. And to avoid that in a typical
permanent hosting space. You need a server where
you want to host it and hugging face the company
the machine learning company that used to be the
NLP company has made it really really easy for
anybody who uses radio or stream li to deploy very
simply using an interface basis. So in this video,
I'm going to show you how I've taken an
existing python script and then translated into
a great new application and then how are we going
to deploy that. So the first thing if you see I
am using radio and transformers I am installing
both this libraries and from import radio as here
and from transformers. I'm importing pipeline
transformers is the hugging page library
pipeline is what we are going to use to
build a very simple sentiment analysis tool.
So the pipeline name is sentiment analysis because
that is the task that we are trying to do. And
after we do this thing, we are downloading all
the pre trained models you can see the model
because we have not specified any specific model
it has been defaulted to distill bird bass and Ks
fine tune SST to English. It's basically a fine
tuned version of distal Bert. After that we need
an important function. So basically anything you
want to do with If you're brand new application,
you have to wrap it around a function. So here in
this case, we are doing a very simple function.
So the function name is get sentiment, and
then it has an input text and it returns
as the sentiment output, the output would look
like this, I'm not formatting the output here,
I'm just leaving it out. Because I want it to
be simple for you to deploy the application,
I don't want to take a lot of time off you to
modify whatever I'm trying to do. So it's going
to be very simple Grady obligation. So the output
is just a text that looks like this. After that,
our function is at this point ready. So gets
increment function is ready, input is ready, and
then the output is ready. And then we have also
tested it right. So I can I can write something
saying that this course is super awesome. Okay,
so that's my narcissistic view of this course.
So it says it's positive, it's 97%. Positive,
that's a good thing. So it's positive and 97%.
And whatever you want to do, like, for
example, this, this course is terrible.
So probably it should say it's negative. Well,
it, yeah, it says negative. So basically, we have
managed to build a sentiment analysis solution
using the deep learning model, which is distilled.
And then with just few lines of Python code,
thanks to hugging face. Now, what we have to
do next is we have to take this script, the
few lines of Python code and translate into a
radio application. And for that, we all know if
you have watched all the videos of this course,
you would have probably known that we are going
to say gr dot interface interface, ie with caps,
upper caps, the function name, the input text,
we have only one text and then output text, we
have another only one text as output. And also we
have the title, the title is sentiment analysis,
we can also add a description if you want, we can
say add, get sentiment, negative slash positive
for the given input. Okay, so we have managed
to create the interface that looks like this
maybe better ways to do like this, this would
increase readability. But again, I don't know
why am I spending time on this thing, but every
Okay, so right now we have defined the interface
with the object a phase. Now all we have to do is
launch a phase. Let's see when we launch a phase.
So again, you don't have to do this on collab,
you can do it on your local machine. And then
then finally, you know, connected with your
hugging face pieces, get and then upload it,
I don't want to touch my local machine at this
point. That's the whole reason I'm doing this.
Because I assume that a lot of people
might be trying to do this using collab.
So that's why I want this deployment experience
to be how you would do it on collapse. So
we have the title, we have the description,
we have the input text. So let's go ahead
and then say this course, is freaking
awesome. And I want little quarter
this seriously narcissistic, but I would take
it still. So it's a label positive, we have
this thing again, like I said before, we are not,
we are not formatting output. So just take text,
I'm throwing it just for the demo purpose.
So now at this point, our sentiment analysis,
application is up and ready. Now let's see what
we are going to do with hugging face faces.
First, go to Google, and then
probably say hugging face spaces,
you would get this, you need to sign in. If
you're hugging face spaces are meant recently made
open for everybody. So it's out of beta. So if
you if you go if you have a hugging face account,
you can log in with that if you do not have, you
have to click click create a new account. So I
already have a hugging face account. So I'm going
to use login. I'm going to use my username sorry.
And then I'm going to use my password. And I'm
trying to log in. So this is how my initial
dashboard or my space front page looks like. So
now we have to create a new space. So I'm going
to create click spaces. After I click spaces, I
can create new space. Let me see if I can change
the theme. The dark theme to
light theme No, I couldn't change.
I hope it is readable for all of you. So
click create new space. You can read the
documentation if you want. You can read you
know like what is what you can do with the
stream written radio what kind of things you can
do, how do you go about like the best practices
all these things? So the good thing is all
the models that are available in hacking face
hugging face transformers are also available for
you here with less hassle. So create a new space.
After you create a new space. We have to give
a space name so I'm going to call it and radio
sentiment analyzer. Is there a good name,
okay. And the SDK that we want to use
so great SDK. And do you want it to be public
or private, of course, I'm habitable from
public. So at this point, you can see
there is no application file your space,
when you open the app, it shows the like, there
is nothing here. So you have to do certain things.
For example, you can clone this repository,
if you're familiar with Git, you can clone
this repository on your local machine. And
then you can create a simple app.py file,
and then that app.py file can can you know, show
can be served as an application. And after you
create this on your local machine, then all you
have to do is add the file to your Git commit
the file, and then push it and then it would come
here to this particular folder, and then your app
is available to be served. But on the other hand,
what we are going to do is we are going to do
everything on the browser, because like I said, if
somebody wants to try it out, just based on Google
collab, like you have already used Google collab
your local machine is not powerful enough, you'd
have you don't know get, you don't have rights.
So to get if you are in any of these categories,
then preceding section is for you. So I'm going to
use the Create button at the last. So let's open
the Create dot app, create app.py file the new
tab, and then we have to copy our code one by one.
So you can copy one by one, or in my case, I've
already copied everything. So I'm going to paste.
So the first line is to import radio. The second
line is to transfer like import pipeline from
transformers. Then we have the sentiment analysis
pipeline task. And then we have the function
that helps us to get the sentiment, then we have
the interface. And finally we have the launch. And
once we have all these things in place, you can
specify launch in lane is equal to false. As well,
if you if you don't want it to be in like
usually you use inline is equal to false
when you are going to avoid the app to be
embedded within your Google collab notebook,
like if you wanted to build on separately. So now
at this point, everything is ready, let's go ahead
and then commit the new file we have successfully
committed and you can see it is trying to build
but it will end in a building error. The reason
why it will fall in a building error is because
we have to install the Transformers
library. So even though hugging phase
spaces is actually on hugging phase still, you
have to manually install the Transformers library
and also torch which has a dependency for
transformers library. Before we install the
library right now there is an error, that's
completely fine. I just wanted to highlight
the readme. So if you're using this template,
by default, you are sorted out. But if you are
not using this, then then you need to make sure
that you have this Yamal at the top, clearly,
because this is what this is really important.
Without this part, the Yamal part of the talk,
your app would not be rendered properly on Korean
face. So you have the title, you have the emoji,
you have the color, and you have the
app file SDK, and the app file, which is
actually used to create serve the application.
So let's quickly go ahead and then create a new
requirements dot txt file requirements dot
txt. Oops. And then we need two things. One,
we need a torch. Second thing we need
transformers. So ideally, we should be able to.
So the first thing is they are going to install
these applications, libraries. And after that,
they will render our app dot phi and our
app.pi. Because we have already tested it
should be successfully running. Let's see.
You can you can never be sure. Okay. It says
it's running. So let's copy this URL,
go to a new tab, and then paste it. Oh,
wait, I think I got a little exited. You have
to copy the entire URL, go back here, paste it.
And then see, okay, it has successfully managed
to work. And also it has got the dark theme
that is that goes well with the interface dark
theme that we have spaces. So I'm going to give an
input text, probably I think I'm tired of seeing
that discourse is awesome. So maybe for a change,
to say radio is awesome. And I thank the
developers for this amazing tool. Let's submit.
Okay, it's positive. So maybe I can say Java
sucks. And then you have negative so you have
basically positive and negative. And at this
point, you have successfully managed to build
a full fledged machine learning deep learning
powered application deployed at Deep Learning
powered radio application, and successfully
deployed it on hugging face spaces. Now you
can copy this link and then give it to anybody.
If you if you want anybody to use the API. Again,
you have this thing also available for you.
So you have successfully managed to learn
everything from building a simple grading
application to improving the UI of the application
and then finally hosting or deploying your
application permanently on hugging face paces for
free at this point, I don't know whether they'll
charge us later, but at this point for free, which
you can share it with anybody in the world. Thank
you so much. Congratulations, we have reached the
end of this course. Thank you so much for watching
this course. And I hope you found this course
really valuable in learning how to build a machine
learning web application using radio and also to
deploy the application. You could use this for
a lot of different purposes as it is described
in the course. And I would love to see the radio
application that you have built during the course
of this course. If you have any more questions,
please let us know in the comment section, you can
always reach out to us on Twitter. And also please
make sure that you subscribe to our channel and
share it with your friends. I wish you the best
for your machine learning journey. Happy coding